المزيد تنتمي لنا من بغداد جميله زينب
المشاط مراسله صباح العربيه اهلا يا زينب
هلا بهالطله اهلا بك
طلت الحصان ولا طله زينب صباح الخير
[ضحك]
تفضل يا زينب معك
بدايه الرحله تحدث عن الربل الربل طبعا
عرفها العراقيون عام 1918 بعد ان يستورد
احد العراقيين من الهند 10 عربات للربل
وبدا يعني يشغلها في
العاصمه بغداد
وبعدها عام 1940 بدا العراقيين يصنعون
الربل واعرفوه في ذلك الوقت الوقت كاسرع
وسيله للنقل العائله الوحيده اللي بقيت
همم الى اليوم محافظه على مهنتها في مجال
همم سياقه او قياده العفو الرمل واللي هم
يعرفون بالعربي
اللي هو العربي يمشي هم عائله ابو حيه
عن عن المهنه هو حفيده احمد احمد اليوم
راح يحدثنا عن سبب اصرار بالاحتفاظ بهذه
المهنه وسبب اسرارها بالاحتفاظ بهذه
العربه تحديدا صباح الخير احمد صباح النور
فمحتفظين بيها شغلنا وعملنا به نطلع مرات
وانسى بيها عالم تخابرني اجور تصوير بنطلع
بيها
طيب احمد من الناس
وبهذه العرب شلونكم تفاعل وياهم وياك يعني
جيت راسي
طيب انت ذكرت انه تستخدم هذه العربه اليوم
طبعا هي ما تستخدم كوسيله نقل اليوم لكن
انت تستخدمها بمناسبات حدثنا يعني عن ابرز
المناسبات اللي استخدمت بها هذه العربه
تصوير اعمال مثلا فنيه اعراس
ممثلين
مسرحيات نطلع بيها
فحدثنا عن هاي العرب
شلون تقول المحترفين من بيعهن هسا مرات
تبيعون هاي من بيعهن نطلع الونسي اللي هاي
العايدين مراتك
وشغل يصير نطلع فيه كلياتهم محرم نستخدمهم
مال مواكب مواكب نطلع بيهم
مبلغ جيد بانه يشتري هاي العربه خاصه
اليوم العديد من المتاحف التراث
يه
هم عرضوا عليك
طبعا ما اتطور الزمن يا سهام ونادين وتطور
وسائل النقل لكن تبقى الوسائل القديمه
الها يعني متعتها ولها الخاص فاذا انتم
عندكم سؤال الضيف يعني اسمعكم يعني احنا
فقط عندنا هيك مداخله انه دائما بنقول في
سر بهذه العربات في اي بلد كان يعني اي
بلد بتروحيه بنحب انه نركب هاي العربي
ونحنا كبنات والتربينا على افلام امل
بانتظار تتحرك ونشوف الجوله في العاصمه
مرعوبه يعني اصلا ههه وزينب كمان بدي اقول
لك انا من الناس اللي تربيت على افلام
ديزني واميرات ديزني فكانوا دائما ان
مرتبط هذه العربي باميرات ديزني كنا
ننظرها كمان منذ الصغر
بنظره حب وحابين انه كمان نركب هذه العربي
هذه فقط مدخلتي
شكرا زينب المشاط نورتيني شكرا جزيلا لك
دائما